like BD first mentality all the time
right new client acquisition is so
important you've got to be going out
there and and speaking to people that
hire in your space all the time I think
there's a tendency that sometimes people
land big accounts and then they just
flip into delivery mode and it's like
you know everything's sweet I've got all
these jobs but you know I've had it
happen to me I've got complacent with it
and had a big account and they turn the
tap off and you're back to to nothing
and you need to uh back out and win
business from from scratch again so I
think spinning that plate all the time
is new business always business
mentality new business mentality but